so B has been real sneaky she keeps
trying to get out of this barricade look
at you so what we're going to do is
we're quickly going to set this camera
up and I'm going to leave for a couple
minutes and see what she
does front
door look at her she is like the
tur see how this goes hey noticed me and
Cat are both wearing our so so happy
hoodies cuz we're so happy look at
that
she did she did Sitting on the she might
have
no lit on how did she get out this is
all
intact I don't understand she didn't how
did she do that well good thing we got
on film
little devil puppy thanks for watching
guys be sure to check out cat's Channel
who is the owner of beta and if you guys
are wondering why we have to put her in
the kitchen it's because I'm super
allergic to dogs and uh don't forget to
subscribe check out my last video and
also uh have a good day yeah peace out